agree with that I'm not on that train
I'm not on that trailer
I just have a problem with the message
and the message okay but here do you
hear it in his voice it's like I can
hear it almost when guys I don't know
what it is or why they talk like that
but it's like when guys are more simply
they have like a higher pitched voice I
don't know why and I was thinking I was
talking to this um woman today she's
called the transformed wife on Twitter
and she's was talking about how God
naturally made men leaders and gave them
deeper voices and I was like maybe the
men that don't that aren't as good in
like leadership or whatever have like
higher pitch voices